[Música]
a
las conversaciones desarrolladas por el
opositor henrique capriles con ciertos
sectores de la diplomacia europea al
margen de juan guaidó hoy de los eeuu
más el rechazo de la también opositora
maría corina machado a la hoja de ruta
de la oposición han detonado un todos
contra todos pero básicamente ha sido la
propuesta de henrique capriles radonski
de acudir a los próximos comicios
legislativos del 6 de diciembre para
ganarle espacios a nicolás maduró lo que
ha provocado un verdadero divorcio en la
oposición en estos momentos
henrique capriles radonski ha impulsado
la inscripción de 227 candidaturas a
través del partido fuerza del cambio
integrada por diversas agrupaciones de
la sociedad civil por diputados y por la
patronal empresarial todo esto ha
ocurrido sin la aprobación de juan
guaidó de 27 partidos que apuestan a la
abstención el próximo 6 de diciembre el
futuro de la oposición es incierto en
estos momentos juan guaidó se mantiene
firme con su ruta de unión y de no
llevar a cabo lo que él llama el fraude
electoral
henrique capriles se mantiene también
con su nueva
de ir a elecciones sin tomar en cuenta a
juan guaidó quien aún lidera las
encuestas como el principal dirigente
opositor en el país
[Música]
europea sigue de cerca la situación en
venezuela a tres meses de las elecciones
legislativas el presidente de venezuela
nicolás maduro invitó por carta al jefe
de la diplomacia europea
josep borrell a que el organismo actúe
como observador en los comicios una
propuesta que aún se está estudiando
aseguran desde bruselas esta propuesta
de maduro se produjo tan sólo un día
después de que excarcelará a más de 100
prisioneros políticos y opositores al
régimen un gesto que según josep borrell
va en la buena dirección y es una
condición sine qua non para que haya
unas elecciones libres e inclusivas e
independientes el susepu rey de momento
sigue en contacto con los líderes de la
oposición en el país también con el
gobierno de nicolás maduro de cara a los
comicios pero también como una forma de
que la unión europea trata de mediar en
el conflicto político y social que vive
venezuela
[Música]
la casa blanca se estaría preparando
para endurecer las medidas en contra de
venezuela y de nicolás maduró debido a
la presión frente a las elecciones
presidenciales el próximo noviembre 3 y
es que el competidor del presidente de
donald trump
joe bayrén por el partido demócrata en
varias oportunidades ha asegurado que el
presidente ha fallado que su política
hacia venezuela ha sido un fracaso y que
no ha logrado sacar a maduro del poder
por esta razón el departamento de
comercio estudia la posibilidad de
anunciar nuevas medidas petroleras
después de que el presidente de unalt on
anteriormente estableciera medidas en
contra de la estatal pedevesa y también
intente cerrar el cerco con otros países
extranjeros que están comprando
intercambiando crudo con venezuela
[Música]